welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition and why did
kong fall off the empire state building
because he had a plane to catch air
having that
well you know we had to start with a
crap joke but we've got some serious
stuff to talk about
now this is a video i've wanted to make
for a while but just never got around to
covering it because of the constant
production troubles that the movie faced
godzilla versus kong is sort of becoming
a myth in its own right
after it's faced several delays and
setbacks in the run-up to its release
so if the long-awaited clash of the
titans is killing you then fear not
as throughout this video we'll be going
over all of the rumored plot leaks
the brand new spoilers and everything we
know so far obviously there will be
heavy spoilers here
so if you don't anything rune then go
play ping pong with king kong
because we're talking about it all as
always take leaks like this with a pinch
of salt
but we will be adding in the evidence to
support what we can
where we can now make sure you subscribe
to the channel for videos like this
every day
and please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy
the content without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our breakdown of the godzilla
vs kong plot leaks
okay so let's start with the official
plot synopsis for the movie
which sets the stage for what's going to
happen the story that was released by
warner brothers
says the following in regards to the
film fearsome monsters
godzilla and king kong square off in an
epic battle for the ages while humanity
looks to wipe out both of the creatures
and take back the planet once and for
all
that was pretty good now obviously
there's gonna be a fight but there's
also a wild card that's been added to it
and that is mecca godzilla because the
movie was meant to release this year the
toys were fully in production
and these revealed mechagodzilla and a
kong that will be wielding an axe like
weapon which we'll discuss in just a bit
according to plot leaks from the test
screening that were posted on reddit
mechagodzilla will be built from the
bones of the giant skeleton from
godzilla 2014.
mechagodzilla also has the brain of the
remaining ghidorah head from king of the
monsters
which was shown in the post-credits
scene of the movie these elements will
be combined in order to control the
other titans
and it will be the thing that humanity
uses in an attempt to wipe out both the
creatures as mentioned in the plot
synopsis
this is apparently carried out by a
company called apex
which i'm guessing is a play on the term
apex predator
see guys nothing gets past us here now
they keep the head in their lab
and have experimented on it in order to
create a new weapon for humanity
apparently there will be a lot of sci-fi
elements in tech that are similar to
pacific rim
and the universe as a whole will start
to head towards this high-tech
anime-inspired universe so basically the
film will center around kong
challenging godzilla and whilst this is
going on the humans will make a move to
take the two out in one fell swoop
there's reportedly a five minute battle
between the pair in which we don't cut
away at all to the humans
and instead we just see them trying to
kill one another now it was rumored that
godzilla himself would be slightly
different to the one that we saw in king
of the monsters
and that he will have become king titan
godzilla however i've been unable to
fully verify this
and it seems to be made up of more rumor
than fact
now there's a brilliant thread on reddit
that i've compiled the majority of this
information from which was brought to
life by sayaka
who's been dropping tidbits on the film
in the run-up to its release
again take this with a pinch of salt but
it does seem to be quite conclusive and
well thought out and put together
now these leaks do mention that godzilla
has a dorsal plate that is similar to
king of the monsters
and the fact that this has been brought
up in the first place does make me
question if the king rumors
a new form could possibly be seen in the
film the league state that godzilla at
one point completely decimates the city
and it is possible that this could be
due to mechagodzilla controlling him
but i am sort of joining the dots there
and just guessing
this could possibly come early on in the
film and it may lead to godzilla
disrupting the peace that kong has lived
with for decades
as for kong his territory now is the
hollow earth due to the radiation there
we learn in the film that the radiation
on skull island became
more and more limited over time which
ended up with kong's lineage becoming
smaller and smaller
this ties back to skull island and helps
to explain why this kong was so big
whilst his ancestors were smaller so in
order to remedy this
he's been roaming around the hollow
earth for the nutritional value it
provides
there are supposedly a bunch of
additional titans here and ones that
we've seen in other movies
new ones also include nuzuki who's a
giant snake like titan
the human storyline will revolve around
exploring the hollow earth
and learning more and more about the
titans and the civilizations that
worshipped and feared them
kong will be disrupted by the attack
carried out by godzilla
and this will lead to them facing off
against one another which of course the
humans will be privy to
now we do know that the film will ramp
up to a final showdown that takes place
in hong kong
kong will brandish an axe and the leaks
state that
it's not a simple axe but rather an
incredibly cool weapon
that he's fashioned from a large boulder
and giant tree
this is how he's approaching the fight
and how the character will level the
playing field
according to the spoilers kong will
climb a building at one point
and godzilla will try and shoot him down
with his atomic breath
the battle is meant to be incredibly
epic and the leaks state that it's very
very violent godzilla will unleash his
new powers that will overpower kong a
lot of the fight
whereas kong is meant to be quite basic
in terms of fighting
relying purely on brute strength it will
lead to godzilla actually winning
and beating kong and now we're unable to
fully confirm this
from all the leaks i've checked out they
do lean towards this being the outcome
this leads to godzilla being the king of
the monsters and kong
well just being poor old kong and not
king kong
after the fight is over the pair will be
badly damaged and recovering
which is when mechagodzilla will arrive
as i'm sure you know with most versus
movies
the films often end with a new foe being
introduced at the last second
and then the pair have to put their
differences aside and team up
to punch punch them in the face now
apparently the toys do
not do mechagodzilla justice and he's
also got powerful energy weapons
he's meant to resemble the shower design
but does not have missiles for fingers
now the leaks go on to say that the pair
do manage to beat mecha godzilla
but that one could perish in the fight
this is mentioned in the leaks
but absolutely nowhere online have i
been able to find out whether this is
the case
so i'm still a bit unsure personally if
they were to kill one i would lean more
towards it being kong
as opposed to godzilla because he's
where the money is
and is pretty much the one heading up
the franchise however it is possible
that they could pull the rug out from
under us kill godzilla
or maybe not even kill any of them at
all now these leaks are subject to
change
and it seems that the movie has been
through several do-overs and screenings
in order to reassemble the film's plot
these show that the delays aren't or bad
news and according to the leaker
because of the additional time that's
been granted the cgi has been
massively improved leading to a much
stronger film visual effects-wise
now before we get into my thoughts on it
i just want to let you know we're giving
away a free copy of the mcu infinity
saga box set to one random subscriber
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the leaks in the comment
section below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 15th of july and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
price
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part okay so as a whole i think that the
movie sounds
really good i'm glad that they're
pushing more towards the battle between
the pair
rather than the human drama which is
something that i feel left the other two
entries
slightly underwhelming people just
really want to see gigantic battles that
ravage cities
and i think it's smart that they're
borrowing from movies like pacific rim
in order to display these as it's what
people want to see
unless you really really like the guy
from kick ass and his wife
which let's face it you don't now films
like this
always come down to their execution but
from what i've heard and seen online
from those that have had test screenings
the movie is delivering the complete
experience in regards to kong and
godzilla
and it will be one of the most epic
titan battles ever put to film
i really hope the delays are worth it
because it sucks that we've had several
release dates for it
but i'm guessing that warner brothers
just want to get everything right before
putting
it out there which is completely
understandable overall there's a lot i
really enjoyed discovering whilst
putting these leaks together
and now that i'm almost fully caught up
and everything i think i'll be trying my
best to keep you up to date with all the
info on the movie as it comes out
so definitely keep an eye on the channel
if you're interested in staying in the
know
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on these leaks if there's anything else
you've heard
and what you want to see in the movie
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of all the new batman news
that we have this week which is going to
be linked at the end
we go over the michael keaton news ben
affleck rumors and a lot more
so it's definitely worth watching if you
want to know more if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early
if you want to come chat to us after the
show either follow us at heavy spoilers
or click the discord link in the
description below
those are the best ways to keep up to
date with the channel and hopefully we
see over there
but if not have a lovely day have a
lovely week have a lovely weekend and i
love you
take care peace
[Music]
ah
[Music]
you